salut pierre barbizet revenus il va
aider casimir enregistré le catalogue
sonore de l'île aux enfants
je crois qu'il va jouer du bétail à
dailan beto c'est tout à fait différent
on dit qu'il est romantique moi je crois
pas qu'ils se romantique métaux
seulement ces deux premiers à s'être mis
en musique avant parler de lui si tu
veux dans la musique
les romantiques qu'est ce qu'ils font on
parle de j'ai pleuré je pleure toujours
il est toujours pleurer et romantique
ccc la pole et adam un chat et mir états
d'âme alors les et les classiques qui
ont l'état d'âme mais il en parle pas
beaucoup tandis que les caciques il a
loué il en parle beaucoup alors béton
dell avait justement il avait un ami
qu'il allait mais beaucoup qui s'appelle
l'archiduc rodolphe et un jour on a été
chassée d'autriche il est parti en exil
alors beto elle a fait une sonate qui
s'appelle les adieux l'absence et le
retour les adieux cette année comme ce
descriptif ça se dit en allemand les
vols les bémols ça veut dire adieu alors
ici là qu'il a fait ça
et puis la réponse
[Musique]
ses deux amis
non
[Musique]
c'est le départ
à une absence
il se passe rien non seulement les
tristes
où
[Musique]
on sent le romantisme là quand même
lens a fini à
[Musique]
ma joie
non
[Musique]
les cloches et
oh
les gros lot la poste
quand
les décors les postillons
[Musique]
on
serra du rasoir
alors le retour l'arrivée de l'ami cette
explosive ça ça te plaît davantage à toi
ça dépend quelque chose ça décrit des
méta zaillian d'imagés il est génial que
c'était bien mais il ya beaucoup
d'autres grands musiciens et pierre
barbizet va revenir